I've been using the airport pros every
day for the last week and I have to say
that yes these are legitimately really
good but they aren't perfect and they do
have some downsides compared to regular
air Potts I'll let you know exactly what
those are along with who should upgrade
and who shouldn't let's start out with
the biggest concerns that I had when
Apple released the original air pods
they basically freed me from the biggest
downsides of earphones I love using air
pods since they're separate pod design
not only allows me to just put in one
bud and without it being pulled down a
cable or anything else but also the fact
that it doesn't plug my ear so I can be
aware of my environment and then come
the new air pod pros I was worried that
I would lose the awareness due to the
seal but Apple has done some sort of
magic with ambient mode and with the
pros I can actually hear my environment
better now yes I have used similar
features with other headphones but they
usually are just a bit off or sound fake
and digital nothing that I have heard
have come close to the natural accurate
quality of the pros ambient mode a big
part of this can definitely be apples
pressure equalizing vents this thing is
crazy a big reason why I don't often use
my galaxy buzz is that like most in ear
ear buds they cause pressure in your ear
when you insert them which makes them a
little bit less comfortable but like
most people I don't complain about this
because that is the norm with this style
in this design but at the same time not
having that pressure is something I love
about the regular ear pods and Apple
figured out how to get the best of both
worlds
with the pros it's actually kind of
weird you put them in your ear gets
plugged as normal but about two seconds
later you feel that pressure go away Wow
with that said one thing I found in the
last week is that for long listening
sessions even with this new ambient mode
the pressure valve and no plastic tip
going into your ear they're not as
comfortable as the regular ear pods for
very long listening sessions but still
much more comfortable than other earbuds
like the Galaxy buds or powerbeats pros
now on to battery life and it is
fantastic I was a bit worried based on
Apple's lower rating based on high
volume playback but in my experience it
she seemed better than my fresh pair of
air pods to searching online I found the
sound guys review where they got about
an extra hour of battery life with the
pros at about 75 decibels and that was
actually a witness cancellation turned
on I fix it found that the pros battery
is almost twice as big as the regulars
so that makes sense on to the charging
case and now has two battery cells
instead of one and of course it is
slightly larger I do have a few pair of
tighter jeans and with those the pros
larger case was more noticeable in my
pocket
not a huge difference but it is
something worth mentioning
next comes the controls I have never
loved the tapping that was required
before but it did work and now having to
grab and press a little stem sounded a
bit weird at first but after about a
week I liked it way more as soon as you
press there's a little audible click
telling you that your interaction was
registered and now that I'm used to it
it feels way better than tapping on the
pod and it also allows for more options
as well now on to audio quality I have
heard everything from it sounds about
the same to wow these sound way better
and I'm on the latter end but it really
matters what and where you're listening
listening to podcasts and audiobooks has
the least amount of quality difference
since both can reproduce voices quite
well but what does help a ton is the
noise cancellation especially if you're
listening out lower volumes or in loud
environments the first audio comparison
I did was with a pretty bassist Ong on
YouTube and I didn't notice that much of
a difference I then listen to some EDM
rock and classical which really showed
the difference the more complex the
track the more that the pros shine and
along with that the higher quality the
audio the bigger the difference I
started a title trial and compared with
some master files and man there is a
massive difference there but like I said
if you listen to simple bass heavy
tracks especially in really compressed
formats you're not gonna notice that big
of a difference overall they sound very
good and balanced without too much
exaggeration and flatter than the highly
praised and often compared Sony WF 1000
XM threes one a name as you
as conceived by the sound guys test but
it still offers a nice rich sound that
most people will really enjoy another
concern that I had was loudness I
absolutely love how loud the air pots
can get which they kind of have to in
order to drown out other sounds whereas
the sealed Galaxy buds are often too
quiet
especially when you have tracks that are
not normalized properly and that does
become an issue
the first Basie track that it compared
with sounded a fair bit quieter with the
pros so I was worried but listening to
better quality content the volume seemed
about the same and then playing master
tracks on title resulted in the pros
being louder than the air pods the only
way that this makes sense is that the
pros have inward facing mics that will
actually equalize the audio specifically
for your ears as well as limit
Distortion meaning that low-quality
songs were likely tuned down to limit
Distortion but high quality tracks are
allowed to play louder I can't prove
this but everything else points to this
conclusion and with good quality audio
loudness is not a problem the last thing
that I want to cover is noise
cancellation there are only a few times
that I grab other headphones instead of
air pods and that's mostly when I need
to block out noise with the pros I won't
have to look elsewhere or bring two
pairs of headphones to get noise
cancellation when I go on trips now they
aren't as good as the over year 1000 M X
3s or XM 3's whatever their naming
scheme is but they do sound about on par
to the N 68k G's that I have that I
would often take with me to supplement
the air pods that give noise
cancellation is more than good enough so
now I could just travel with the air
pods and not have to take other
headphones with me so overall what did I
learn in the last week
well first off Apple has a clear winner
on their hands with good audio they
sound fantastic the battery life is
great comfort is class leading handling
is improved and noise cancellation is
good enough to replace dedicated
headphones I also learned that if you
listen to low quality audio especially
with those that don't have a lot of
things going on as far as instruments
and sounds the audio quality difference
isn't huge and you shouldn't upgrade
just for that comfort is good
if you wear regular ear pods and they
fit well and you use them for very long
periods of time say three four or five
hours they're still slightly more
comfortable due to not having anything
that actually goes into your ear canal
if you're on the fence deciding if it is
worth the extra money when buying or
upgrading I would say for most it
definitely is thank you guys for
watching if you guys want to see our
full review of the air pods Pro you guys
can click right over there we also have
another comparison coming up with the
galaxy buds and the echo buds that come
in for just one hundred and twenty nine
dollars so make sure you guys subscribe
by clicking a little circle above and
enabling notifications down below this
has been max with Max SEC and I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]